oh hello my name is markiplier and
welcome to friend yoga and and maybe
wondering where's my friend okay hi
welcome to friend yoga we have
pre-selected some yoga poses yes we
tweeted out to you guys about yoga poses
that we could do with two people not and
so we're going to do that for you right
now
ready ready the first pose whoo easy
we should do that at any time and you
can see it right here
swing which arm first this one for this
one for the whole thing's get lower good
alright I'm gonna put an official nailed
it put it in a love affair with an
explosion and glitter
why did you remember like the videos
were those people were dancing on each
other
I was this pug but then this is Russian
I like that around my ass you guys both
do like one you should take turn goes
well if you want to share the NASS
ramming experience okay sit down big boy
is about to get comfortable
shove it in there good thing you picked
out my butt hole before this yeah I want
a closer look on you we nailed it
apparently we got it
you wouldn't be other guys doing that
he's been reliably a possibility nothing
sorry whatever okay all right now oh you
people doing yoga does it instructor
helping somebody we still do it
all right let me help you you need to
get your hips best buddy
yeah it's good good all right and now I
turn all right make sure undress we all
do it this way tammer Tom all right that
was a good feed less yeah okay
that was nailed it well who loved cat
[Music]
who you want to be bottom or top we
should do it both I love sharing
relationship well you want to push up
with me on you we gotta push it at the
same time I think my phone okay all
right fine I'm resting my ankles on your
shoulders is this good yeah your legs
can take this my lips can take it here
we go part three q1 plus then we do
anyone know me I wanna go right here
yeah right there dude
all right three two one nailed it all
right we're next
oh okay can I get a second yeah I think
I can do that
okay how's your feet flat on and EE legs
going this Oh God oh yeah has the back
your head towards me
yeah I know I'm gonna flip oh jeez how
else would I do it I don't know but I'm
gonna have you start with you I'm gonna
come down hard and the law of your spine
[Music]
all right you're turning Oh Georgia
how's the man about cutting down on the
spine all right
I'm scared doing it slippery ready I can
take it no I don't trust myself
the only other side drops on Bertha you
can do it if you won like leaving like
it look with one leading leg your honey
your choker
then we have it yeah we gotta clear from
the judges kitty I just imagined the
teetering log like a whole tree just
falling have you ever seen those
Japanese log catching competitions I
mean I think it's great with the
guidance show that video right now yes
that's how was that salad no be
Photoshop that no no that got to be full
of stuff there's no way it's chin to
ground
[ __ ] in hands I think we could do that
let's push up position okay you got it
cool sweaty
what are your ankles swing but sweaty
boyes you're an equal do every part of
me what Oh real sweaty oh man all right
you know we just got to go for it should
my spine can't push it better there
oh I bet it looks complicated but I bet
it's not that bad it's a headstand yeah
we slap the head spin heads behind so we
got to be head to head touching we're
gonna be touching a head to head
interlock legs through the crotch yeah
and once the bar left legs no right legs
yeah no right leg your right right leg
right leg who's more confident in the
head spin
hi okay I kind of be ready to do that
it's elbows arms and head yes you got a
little bit rough on your you got that I
think the more confident person should
go to second okay yeah that's been true
okay all right so what am I supposed to
do here put this put it down put it down
put it away
I've got to go in blind so I'm gonna
peel out with my right foot where's we
where the split up where's the foot
where's the foot love it more wanton
against me all right where is it where
is it are you that livid semion do this
do this cool [ __ ]
[ __ ] this art he pushed me I'm tried
that maybe we gotta [ __ ] our legs first
with other leg on the ground and then
pull ourselves up maybe yeah my right
leg up get worse is that it yeah okay
I don't know it turned into a wall out
of it's gonna work we into this went on
our mobile traffic cool just got to hook
that leg so while we look okay be done
enough okay ready yeah
what ah
Oh dead wolf boy who's anyone gentle it
was it was oddly tensile I've never felt
a heal from that gently on my ball
forget it okay cool
if you freeze frame it make it a only
circuit pictures for a second maybe I
couldn't hold that one
I totally flipped completely on me
Ericka Sluka crying you've been better
backwards I don't know
often I'll be on top I'll be on top that
aw damn uh-oh grab my ankles okay
I'm going to start down just lay on top
of me we're going to flex at the same
time okay you're gonna flip okay blades
on your back all right with your hands
against my Achilles okay and your legs
on my shoulder right I'll try it on
push-up position
yes you don't have to little into it you
can just lay down and got me into the
whooping Leela group quick through the
back just roll on there here it's this
way right yes it's this way yeah
oh boy okay all right so there is my
legs all right I got your legs okay are
you gonna be able to push up an hour I
will try all right ready
next bridge baby one I'm crazy Toki oh
because they come to three because I
have to push you up at the same time
okay one more
[Music]
[Applause]
my name is was straitened I realize what
are you going to push up with your hands
is my bag closed alright put aside by
time yeah free clothes are we kissing
well I mean we're not right now we're
about to get real friendly we're about
being real friendly
okay so you just gotta sit wait put the
other way so I can logic this to my
brain so I was just going to sit on your
feet and lay back and lay back and I got
to grab your ankle you're lucky I'm
inflexible I don't think I'm gonna face
that I think we did just this one I
don't think that my back ah
grab my grip here oh yes you
okay you got I got you okay I'm good i
suspend these go record broken
we could even slip Mugen what you know
it's like what babe breaks back man baby
ah his woman's pain break Batman back
that is big bring that back bad when
brain-based
happy send it back all right you get on
bottom your neck oh man I expect a sweet
kiss aren't you cute
oh I'm Harry we're just a flexible lover
not illegible enough Chris how do we do
judge overall score impartial judges I
think we start off pretty good
what we got this score out of what so
that was friend yoga
we're very sweaty that was awesome what
is bring it I'm not bad I think there
are more we can do oh I'm sure there's
more that we can do but maybe we'll do
it in another episode
maybe we'll figure more stuff out get
more flexible as babies keep you Martha
always said you know who loves cats get
guy so thank you everybody so much for
watching let us know how we do down the
comments below and if you guys did yoga
at home with your friend show of
pictures on Twitter
thank you so much for watching and as
always we will see you in the next video
bye hi
[Music]